>> >> WE WILL CONTINUE TO MONIR
THAT PRESS CONFERENCE, AT THE
ANNAPOLIS NEWSPAPER, FIVE DEAD
AND A SIMILAR NUMBER INJURED.
LET'S GO NOW TO OUR OWN
KRISTIN FISHER WHO HAS SOME MORE
DETAILS ON THE STORY.
ARE YOU THERE?
>> WE ARE THERE.
WE GOT MORE INFORMATION FROM
LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THAT PRESS
CONFERENCE AND I JUST WANT TO
RUN THROUGH SOME OF THE
THEY ARE NOW CALLING IS THIS A
TARGETED ATTACK ON THE CAPITAL
GAZETTE NEWSPAPER.
IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER THIS GUNMAN
KNEW SPECIFIC EMPLOYEES OR IF
YOU JUST HAD A GRIPE WITH THE
NEWSPAPER ITSELF BUT WE CAN NOW
CONFIRM THAT THE ATTACK WAS
INTENDED TO BE ON THE CAPITAL
GAZETTE NEWSPAPER WHICH IS A
LOCAL COMMUNITY NEWSPAPER, ONE
OF THE OLDEST NEWSPAPERS IN THE
COUNTRY OWNED BY THE BALTIMORE
SUN.
PREPARED ATTACK.
HE CAME IN THROUGH THE BUILDING,
THIS BUILDING JUST BEHIND ME,
THE BROWN BRICK BUILDING JUST
AND A SHOTGUN, AND HE JUST WENT
THROUGH THE FIRST FLOOR NEWSROOM
OF THE CAPITAL GAZETTE AND
PICKED OFF HIS VICTIMS ONE BY
ONE.
WE KNOW THEY ARE NOW CONFIRMING
FIVE DEAD AND TOO INJURED.
THE TWO INJURED ARE ESSENTIALLY
SUPERFICIAL INJURIES.
FROM GLASS, WHICH WAS BLASTED
OUT FROM THE SHOTGUN.
NOW THEY ARE GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS, A VERY LENGTHY PROCESS
CLUES THERE.
TUCKER, THE OTHER REALLY BIZARRE
TWIST IN THIS STORY IS, ABOUT
THE SHOOTER HIMSELF, WE ARE
HEARING THAT HE MUTILATED HIS
OWN FINGERTIPS, PERHAPS IN AN
WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THAT
MEANS OR HOW HE DID IT.
WAS IT A LONG TIME AGO OR
DIFFICULT TO IDENTIFY HIM.
THEY HAVE HAD TO IDENTIFY HIM
USING FACIAL RECOGNITION
SOFTWARE.
HE DID NOT SHOOT AT THEM.
WE DON'T KNOW IF HE SURRENDERED
OR WHAT THE EXACT CIRCUMSTANCES
THROUGH SOME GREAT EFFORT TO
HIM TO BE IDENTIFIED.
AND THE BIG THING THAT EVERYONE
IS TALKING ABOUT HERE IS THE
THE POLICE HAVE BEEN TRAINING
FOR AN ACTIVE SHOOTER SITUATION
JUST ONE WEEK AGO.
THEY HAD A DRILL TO PREPARE FOR
A SITUATION JUST LIKE THIS AND
THEY WERE ON THE SCENE WITHIN 60
SECONDS.
THE GOVERNOR AND THE MIRRORS
THAT THEY WENT IN WITHOUT
HESITATING.
THEY EXHIBITED TREMENDOUS
COURAGE, AND WITHOUT THEM IT'S
ALMOST CERTAIN THAT THERE WOULD
HAVE BEEN SEVERAL MORE LIVES
BUT JUST A VERY SAD TO SCENE OUT
HERE AND SOME OF THE
DEVELOPMENTS THAT WE ARE HEARING
REALLY ARE QUITE BIZARRE.
A FINAL WORD OF CAUTION, WE
SHOULD BE GETTING ANOTHER UPDATE
LATER TONIGHT BUT
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS NOW TELLING
US THAT WE ARE NOW MOVING FROM
THE ACTIVE SHOOTER AND RECOVERY
PHASE TO THE INVESTIGATIVE
PHASE.
THIS IS THE PHASE THAT OBVIOUSLY
TAKES THE LONGEST PERIOD OF TIME
AND THEY URGE THE PUBLIC AND
URGE THE PRESS FRANKLY TO BE
PATIENT WITH THEM TO MAKE SURE
THEY GET THE FACTS STRAIGHT.
WITHOUT A DOUBT, THE BIGGEST
QUESTION TONIGHT IS MOTIVE.
WHY DID HE DO THIS, WHY DID HE
HOLD A GRUDGE AGAINST THE
NEWSPAPER, WAS IT SOMETHING THAT
WAS SAID IN THE PAPER THAT HE
DIDN'T LIKE?
>> Tucker: LET ME STOP YOU AND
SAY, THERE ARE REPORTS THAT
THERE IS A HISTORY OF ANIMUS OR
EVEN LEGAL ACTION BETWEEN THIS
MAN AND THE NEWSPAPER, WE CAN'T